okay let's get right into debunking a
growing right wing talking point against
Medicare for all and against other
single-payer type plans because what we
have now is a situation where the right
is very much on the defensive because
the viability the superiority of plans
like Medicare for all has been
increasingly demonstrated over the last
several years there's no question that
there are still details to sort out
there are assumptions to fine-tune but
the right recognizes that Medicare for
all is more and more popular it's more
and more in demand the current system is
being identified by more and more people
as immoral and dysfunctional
dysfunctional and unsustainable so the
right has had to come up with new
arguments that they can use as a crutch
and the argument that the right and
actually some of the centrist left are
making more and more is that wait a
second
Medicare for all will kill jobs and to
them I say that's right welcome to
macroeconomics you're not actually
making an argument when you say that so
let's go through it and we we need to be
armed with this because this is
increasingly something that they are
saying expenditures are someone else's
income I'm going to explain this today
please do send this story out to other
independent left-wing hosts that you
follow so that we can all get on the
same page about the talking point and to
understand the economics behind it
so that we don't allow them to use this
terrible argument against us
Medicare excuse me Medicare for all
would reduce the number of jobs in the
health insurance sector and in some
other areas of health care this is not
something we need to hide from it's
instead something that we need to put in
context and simply meet head-on the late
of a Reinhart who was a supporter of
single-payer systems pointed this out in
his latest book it's a book I've
recommended to you called priced out
healthcare spending is income for people
who work in the field and that includes
profits it includes lots of salaries and
includes costs of treatment and
facilities but that spending is income
on the other side if you reduce health
care spending say by 20%
you could be reducing healthcare
employment by roughly the same 20% I'm
using crude math it's not dollar for
dollar but for our argument today it's
good enough this is not special to
health care this is a reality for any
move by a government which reduces costs
which can be called spending this is
called the circular flow of income in
economics you have GDP gross domestic
product which is roughly equal to a
country's income which is roughly equal
to a country's production which is
roughly equal to a country's total
spending this is the heart of
macroeconomics they're not making an
argument when they say medicare-for-all
will kill jobs they just don't
understand what that means
it's not a perfect equation but
fundamentally when someone says Medicare
for all would kill jobs what they mean
is spending as much as we do on health
care funds a lot of unnecessary jobs
that we don't need and make health care
way more expensive the next question if
you want to go down this path is is it
worth switching to a Medicare for All
system given that it would reduce
employment broadly speaking within the
health delivery field I'll give some
examples when a government says we've
got to cut spending on education it's
become too bloated and they say let's
reduce spending on education by 10
percent they're talking about reducing
income for people working in education
by 10 percent spending on education is
income for people working in education
this could be everybody gets a 10% pay
cut it could be we layoff 10% of the
people working in education again we're
looking at the numbers at a crude macro
level in the real world you can find
ways to trim costs that less directly
affect employment but someone's revenue
or income or profit is being cut that's
a reality the point is when the right
c-span
as not worthwhile when they don't like
what we're spending money on they say
we've got to do some responsible
spending cuts and we've got to save some
money when the right wants the spending
because it's fueling an industry or a
sector that they like they call an
attempt to cut spending a job killer
it's a political football much like debt
and deficit I'll give you one more
example the coal industry the coal
industry should die coal has horrible
negative externalities pollution causes
illness hurts the planet it's
inefficient it's antiquated but if you
reduce the coal industry by 90 percent
you cut roughly ninety percent of those
jobs and that's okay sometimes
industries are obsolete we need to
figure out how everybody can keep making
a living they need to people are gonna
need to find other jobs but the argument
that we should just prop up coal so that
people don't lose coal jobs is just as
bad as saying we shouldn't do
medicare-for-all because some people
will lose jobs it's a political football
it's like debt and deficit we've talked
about it before so then it becomes a
question of given that every economic
policy affects jobs at a macroeconomic
level what is worth doing if we cut
education spending by 10 percent we're
cutting teachers by 10 percent this will
worsen education it will continue to
make us less competitive globally in
industry it'll generate more crime since
more educated people commit less crime
it is not good for the economy over the
long term if we cut Medicare if we cut
health care spending with something like
Medicare for all we eliminate medical
bankruptcies we put more money in
people's pockets to reinvest into the
economy by going to local businesses we
eliminate people keeping a job they hate
just because they need to keep that
health insurance plan we eliminate
people being sicker because they forego
earlier treatment to maybe avoid the
costs associated with going into the
doctor and yes that will be associated
with a reduction in employment in the
healthcare field including a lot of
bloat like medical coding insurance
fraud investigators so on and so forth
isn't that worth it there have been job
realignments in
the United States forever other large
economies have had technological
advances and changes that reduce
employment within certain industries
priorities change this is nothing new
it's not an argument to say but that
will kill jobs so don't fall for it
don't fall for the trap of accepting
that any government policy it's like you
know how the right says the left uses
I'm offended to stop conversation as
soon as they say I'm offended they end
the conversation the right says that
policy will kill jobs and they use it
like a cudgel similarly to just end a
conversation don't accept that just
because a policy reduces employment in a
particular industry it's bad and we
shouldn't do it economies adjust with
our help with our planning and on the
other side of the equation you will have
healthier people who are more
economically productive you will have
people in job as they like rather than
jobs they are keeping just to keep that
high deductible crappy health insurance
plan we cannot allow the right to set
the agenda on this issue and to concern
troll over jobs when it's convenient but
then to call cost reductions savings
when they like them we need to take back
the talking point so let's all get on
the same page on this one like I said if
there's other people you watch who are
trying to deal with this talking point
send them this clip let's get on the
same page because they are using this
talking point a lot and we need to be
prepared to defend against it